luca reagiert mal dass die lampe
leuchtet
hallo mein name ist hässlicher kommt
heute zu einem neuen video ich habe euch
mal wieder bei später gesagt es hat
nicht nur gesagt kostet man bittet ihr
die welche videos wie sie reagieren
werden in het loo carré agieren und ich
würde sagen jetzt angeregt mit dem
ersten video
[Musik]
da ist ein bauer in einem kuhstall und
sagt dass freitag ist und er will mal
wieder so richtig packen wird zwar
gerade sonntag aber wir könnten mal dass
freitag
wir schauen mal wie jetzt auf die kacke
haut wird auch vorgeworfen nur die
beschrifteten video für beschützen
[Musik]
wollte ich auf das alter in der tat mir
wird wirklich auch vorgeworfen
musikvideo luca nimm doch mal andere
videos als bei diesen bescheuerten
videos wenn etwas anderes als betreuten
videos eingeblendet worden werden tun
dann wird noch daran genommen wird ist
aber nicht
er kommt wirklich nur scheiße
[Musik]
du hast bei snap chat oder was überhaupt
hat einkaufen gegessen das rückgeld
abgespielt und ihr dann eine brille und
eine explosion rentiert das hat schon
größeren aufwand als aber leute schaut
einfach wirklich mal selber bei twitter
außerdem heftiger reagiert was also für
video kommt brauche ich doch irgendwas
dazu sagen
[Musik]
das video an welches mega light also wie
herr quasi mit einem ikea oder durch
ikea durch und regte bei luca match aus
dem bundestag und am ende macht sie aus
dieser einsendung von mir irgendwie so
eine art remake das hat mit inge keine
idee gebracht als ich meinen jeder
youtube kennt ja irgendwie an zu
schwingen weil sie damit geld verdienen
die startbahn und ich kann halt nicht
singen aber diese einzige winter sowie
tabletten auf einem kanal die farbe ist
die idee findet dass ich komme jetzt
einfach mal auch tony würdet ihr davon
halten wenn ich dieses lokale schöpfung
den ehemals vom kleinen track
produzieren würde auch gratis spontan
eingefallen aber ich habe kollegen der
die zu produzieren kann grüße gehen raus
an sich david und ich glaube wenn ich
den wir damit an hauen würde dann wäre
der down bei der idee also nachbarn wie
vielleicht machbar 44.000 oder so das
zeigt also das zeigt mir halt einfach ob
ihr wollt oder nicht
vorhin krieg war noch von videos
mädel wirklich gedanken gemacht hat und
mit einem roller durch die gefahr dass
ein paar bewegungen macht hat und jetzt
bekomme ich wow wirklich wow das ist das
darauf darauf habe ich gewartet meine
damen und herren ich hab mir übrigens
eine lichterkette geholt da vorne und
darum einfach leute ich weiß nicht wann
sieht man eigentlich nie in den videos
aber ich werde es so machen
also ich werde allgemein ist mein abitur
machen zum beispiel hier liegt oft
riesiger teppich drin ich werde das ding
machen dass wir so wieder hinstellen
kann wenn andere youtuber jährigen
kommen können wir zusammen videos
aufnehmen da und dahin zu kommen wo play
button und zum bundesrat außerdem wollte
ich eigentlich die komplette band hinten
auf dem court material machen damit ich
eine pinnwand habe unter wochen dran
kann aber das alles pläne die überhaupt
nicht in diesem video passen
doch das könnte eine typische
einblendung von stan sein ich habe ja
auch fan letzten mal gesagt dass er mir
eine neue anwendung schicken soll vorher
irgendetwas andere fragen sollen
irgendwann sagt art heißt ihr es denn
nicht mehr oder überhaupt nicht kennen
das ist ja der die ganze sache mit
tomatensaft ins leben rufen aber bitte
lasst das bärtchen einfach mal aus bevor
ich meine tomaten tag geht noch klar da
kann man nur noch die jeder mensch hat
irgendwie nicht jeder mensch aber viele
menschen formaten bärtiger ich mach mir
die mühe bitter weil ich bestellungen
dabei zu packen und die interne oder
wenn die so behandelt wir haben
vielleicht auch an leber und
familienkonto mehr
deine tempo griechen wehren wenn ich
heute wieder in freiberg würde für die
sinnvolle aussage und
wow
meine taschen küche riecht nach
taschentüchern bis dahin keine retten
die firma hatte da hat jemand einwenden
remix gemacht vom main kanal
der treffer hat
[Musik]
also es ist nicht der beste track auf
einander das bild ist nicht synchron mit
dem ton und so weiter und so fort
gefährdet nicht die karriere könnte aber
hey die idee und die arbeit dahinter
das bringt etwas träge in die augen
es geht um youtube twitter blöd
es geht um youtube enorm viel und
einfach falsch gemacht hat also ihr
müsst das in europa stehen nur weil ich
etwas kritisiere und sagen ey das kann
man da untermieter der fingerspitze also
der hat dann locker stunden an arbeit
reingesteckt
dann machte auch noch geld müsse
überlegen das ganze ding in der rodacher
irgendwie anderthalb minuten das heißt
er hat da locker mit dem gewässer liegen
blieb das hauptthema dieser folge locker
reagiert bisher wirklich musik also
werden bisher schon wieder die
bürgersteige nennung im ikea werden wir
diese youtuber remix und ich hab euch
schon gefragt ob ihren luca wiener
shop.de track von mir mal haben wollen
ich bin im moment wie wahr wie er hinter
mir
du bist bei dem fenster und wartet auf
mich also erste die hinter mir das ist
theoretisch
da wo bist du der nähe
ich komme da für mich dort wieder peter
fries du wirst nicht ordentlich pizza
crêpes
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich komplett verwirrt ich weiß
dass er mit solchen einsendungen mit
wecken möchte aber ja ich weiß es
wirklich nicht mehr ganz großen fischen
anmerkungen noch ebenso zweig und
bewachen und zwar eher bitte tragt euch
den zwanzigsten dritten ganzen kalender
ein und zwar wird highlight dieser rudi
hier mit dem pizza logo gelaunt und
außerdem gibt es dazu auch 1000 sich
mehrere ticker von mir seid wenn ihr
euch von rudi bestellt von dem gibt es
1000 stück dann bekommt ihr einen
signierten sticker und jetzt kommt zur
zweiten wahl ganz kurz ich bin am
siebzehnten dritten das ist ein freitag
in berlin am alexanderplatz im cubix das
glaube ich schon im kino und was die
power rangers film ihre kooperation die
ich mit ihnen gemacht hat und ich glaube
alle stücke sind schon weg aber ihr
könnt trotzdem dahin kommen weil das
wieder ein kleines kind mehr oder
weniger also wenn ihr ihn seit ein
bisschen dritte mich sehen wollt dann
könnt ihr gerne vorbeikommen und machen
weiter mit dem video
ein panda der umfeld also ich meine
videos gegen den süd einzelnen faktor
von dem video weiter nach oben ab zwar
helfe auch nicht so dass spannende video
gucken wir mal dass sie dann beleuchtet
soll reagieren dass die lampe leuchtet
was ich hab auch ne lampe hier da
dasteht wird die lampe und allein mit
meiner top mit dem mit einem lukas meili
aber wie soll ein mensch reagieren das
eine lampe leuchtet die kameras wird
nicht mutig weil ich jetzt was sagen wie
er diese mit einer welser kingsley
solche zusagen die ehe war voll geil ist
eine lampe leuchtet ja voll hammer wie
die steckdose gesteckt hat sich daran
gemacht die leute einfach die brocken
händen
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich wieder
irgendwie leute anfang wegen ich würde
nur seite einblenden oder halt
irgendwelche sachen die mit dem luca job
zu tun haben aber eine ganz kurze frage
an sich die eigene tor hat er fast jedes
produkt auf meinem schon durch die hand
auf dem warum wird mehr zu gelände in
genf er wird ab gemacht okay leute ich
würde sagen wir machen jetzt mal eine
ganz kurze trauer in vielen sekunden
phase für marlies becker
[Musik]
darf ich vorstellen dass mich meine haus
trampte er ist gewählt wer sie ist neun
monate alt welcher mensch hat eine
[ __ ]
was ist überhaupt eine aus pflanzen aber
hey die auf jeden fall herzlichen
glückwunsch dass der hauptstandort
herzlichen glückwunsch auch dass die
schon diplomatisch die ist in valletta
als das neun monate alte freue mich
megamäßig hoffe ich wünsche euch viel
spaß freude und erfolg für die nächsten
monate also ich heute wieder eigentlich
beendet mit tom bitteschön video und
dann kriege ich ein kaninchen das
gegenden land sprintet das war ziel von
video meine damen und herren feiern
würde ich mich freuen wie gesagt weil
wir weiter sind
di luca - hoffnung die einwendung ein
trackball produziere mit david sonst
folgt mit deren bei instagram platz für
sie finden alle gründe in der
beschreibung eingeblendet auch meinen
job und jetzt würde ich sagen hier seht
ihr ein mann die eigene werden wenn er
da drauf klickt könnt ihr meinen kanal
abonnieren darum finden die auch
eingeladen und hier ist das andere video
was ihr euch jetzt anfangen sollte es
bestimmt auch scheiße aber sonntag